i'm sure you've seen people do this
before
well if you've never seen me do it
oh there we go a little bit more i'm
very firstly today very firstly oh here
we go i think that should be enough to
quench my first
here we go guys miss miller
of course i'm not gonna do this
i want to remind you of a woman who
would do really bad acts
but she was forgiven because she used a
shoe to give water to a thirsty dog
imagine sponsoring a prayer pack and one
person learns how to pray salah for the
rest of their life and just imagine that
being your ticket to jannah such little
actions can get someone forgiven if
giving a dog water can get somebody
forgiven just imagine teaching someone
salah these things only happen through
action you guys have to physically tap
your fingers to give a donation click
the button or the link and give 10
prayer packs for 100 pounds in the best
10 days of the year the prophet peace be
upon him said there are no days in which
righteousness which are more beloved to
allah than these 10 days build the salah
for yourself today